oh hello I'm here for the kid
letting cable kill this kid we're gonna
form a super duper group read him tough
morally flexible and young enough to
carry their own franchise for 10 to 12
years oh hello there you may be
wondering why the pink suit well so the
world can see that I have a big ol heart
on that's heart with the T for my new
obsession pink the color not the pop
singer personally I'm more of a saline
kind of guy
pink is hide like a beautiful ribbon to
a cause very close to me cancer so
amazed and I are joining together scare
up some serious cash for [ __ ] cancer I'm
gonna donate the very suit off my back
while giving you a chance to own some
movie marketing memorabilia what you do
from there is limited only by your
imagination will you add it to your
weekly wardrobe rotation who doesn't
become a colorful addition to your S&M
dungeon oh you simply nail it to a post
in order to scare away birds children
and the elderly visit the website below
to get all the details this is one fight
where everyone can be a hero no
superpowers capes or lame CG costumes
needed just your money seriously we need
that these suits aren't cheap
ed - amazed calm forward-slash Deadpool
and together let's f cancer calm
you